ah he's crazy buckles
back off back off hey he's throwing I'm
not throwing anything a lot of the magic
comes in post you know what I mean I
know exactly what you mean but this time
we're just gonna have to wing it
Jubilees geralyn's gr are you connected
to the server yeah where are you I know
it yes good to meet you too man
here in Minecraft it's been a long time
coming for me yeah I'm old-school gamer
I saw that yeah it was great I came
straight at you yep Hey no call it it's
a masterpiece it's it's a little like
like it's like he is like Mozart of
video games
it created a world and it becomes the
biggest game in the world the game
within the game of the world within a
world the only world you need there's a
powerful Shakespearean lesson in in the
knotch story yeah I need to crack it and
I was thinking a lot about it and um you
know this producer who does all of the
MCU the Marvel Comics universe his name
is uh Kevin [ __ ] cuz I really look at
what he's done over the last ten years
yeah where he just like a puppet
mastered all of these stories all of
these movies like 25 movies half of them
billion-dollar franchises now oh really
all leading towards this one
thing with uh with mine crime no it's a
separate thing would have endgame oh I
see
it's a masterstroke of cinema Verte this
guy I think has proven that he's the
only guy to produce knotch the movie so
I just decided right now Kevin fake
you're hired
alright we're just gonna go and pick
some flowers because I need for your
shoot and then we should be all set
look out zombie alone thanks Brett hey
you got an achievement nice yeah
I don't see any chickens would be we'd
be feasting well fine oh there's the
people there's a meatball and let me
show you the meatball Jack you I could
see that meatball literally from a mile
away
that's because it's so beautiful and so
big I don't know if I believe that you
made that meatball entirely on your own
Jack I feel like maybe I left some of
that word minions that's a lot of work
there I said I play a lot of mic so I
appreciate that you you're calling me
out here live so I can defend myself yes
I built it myself thank you very much
and Jack even though you just insulted
my meatball I'm gonna give you this
honorary swedish eel oh all right thank
you just what to do there it is boom
yeah all right all right all right all
right I wish you had a different skin
but this is though if if this wasn't
live there would definitely be a Matthew
McConaughey name right then when you
said that all right all right all right
all right let's check out the meatball
wait I can't open this door now you
gotta hit the button wait button right
click it but it's been it's hidden it's
hidden oh that's yeah of course yeah you
go ahead Jablonski I'll hold the door
open for you okay and then send oh wait
I got to reset it for you
and stand on the thing and then you
gotta send Scylla
well in Sag okay I don't know if this
will work on multiplayer - got it
oh no I don't think I'm supposed to be
in here yeah you're right
so tell me honestly is this the finest
meatball you've ever seen well let me do
of course it is that's it thank you good
look it's like the Death Star of
meatballs ha ha ha I like to see it as
they that meatball could destroy a
planet oh I have an idea follow me
ok so this is the famous I can't our oh
it's beautiful at this time of year do
you know I recently built an Ikea bed
for my son
really and I did it almost all by myself
almost all by yourself I was pretty
proud of it my wife had to come in on
step 2720 some screwing here we go up
there oh yeah
follow me but I also found it oddly
satisfying it was hard work but at the
end of the day it was kind of like Legos
ya know what I mean
where you just follow the directions
yeah I really like building I kiss them
yeah if you follow it really strictly
unless it works hits I did have to call
an Ikea expert at one point at step 29
but they they knew what they were they
were right there with me did they have a
Swedish accent no that was watch - dude
that was a dude from Fresno I was
talking to on the hotline fake IKEA okay
here we are almost at the top
don't push me all right hey is Swedish
accent now forgive my ignorance because
I haven't studied with a Swedish accent
yet is it kind of a flirt heard and
dirty bro this is why you're perfect for
the natural is absolutely perfect all
the way to the top okay careful okay
careful give her love yeah
okay check if you look down don't be
scared mmm yeah you're fine giblets kay
there's something I haven't told you so
my fiance's very first crush was you and
I wish it was what where she was 14 and
I think I think that means I have to
kill you in mine crime I'm sorry
it's like it had to be done
Michael Sara kills I don't know oh yes I
was like number one that's right makes
this surprising and shoving him up oh
okay all right
you want it real you know what you said
it was a challenge let's go all naked
all fists and settle this yeah what'd
you say that you minecraft alright
alright no weapons
oh no weapons no weapons okay where are
you I'm gonna you know what I'll meet
you at the meatball I'm at that all
right I'll meet you the meatball to will
settlement it ended
yeah as as discussed naked as Jaybirds
absolutely that's a Minecraft honor I
want to see those tables you will see
the tables don't you worry
just me I just got to drop all my stuff
all the tables are dropping listen
you've got a lot of edge you've got a
lot of things that you're better at than
me to hand combat might be the place
alright okay alright
hey what about boots can I keep my boots
yeah okay cool hey what was that movie
where Viggo Mortensen was a Russian
mafioso Lord of the Rings
no what's it called not green book no
it's where he was like a Russian where
you go it I'm sorry that's pretty smart
hey you're not nude I asked that's your
body this is my skin
I'm Meghan I swear Eastern Promises
there's a steam room scene where Viggo
Mortensen yeah that's the naked
hand-to-hand combat uh-huh with another
mafioso dude and that's just making me
think of what's about to happen right
here it's going down right now
he's running does everyone see this he's
ready it's tactical he's crazy I'm not
throwing anything I told you how to do
chickens all right
I see no right I only see you turning
right on red stone no way red stone in
my jack I knew it
it wasn't supposed to come out like this
because I loved her inner beauty that's
why she fell in love with me that's
right and that's why you need to die in
mine crap the weight when you yeah
that's what you get from this that's
what you get Jack I'll never even again
wait sorry I was looking for the my oh
there it is there it is here it is you
just put that chicken on the leash
that's right it's all yours dude that is
the sweetest gift anyone's ever
virtually given me you're welcome
you can name them you can do whatever
you want with them he's a man
I will name him [ __ ] mr. perfect name
he'll be the star of the Knoxville but
you know he's still attached to you I
don't know it's like it's not mine okay
okay okay Kay Kay here you're dragging
him along can you let him sell your yeah
thank you you're welcome
it's been a pleasure - I'm glad we
finally got it working at least yeah are
you off with [ __ ] you might want to
watch out [ __ ] oh okay with my bare
hands
bare hands their hands I'll kill this
guy watch we got up to Dixie to the
maple retreat first to the meatball
first to the egg first to the key hey do
you mind if I go in to the meatball and
raid the fridge I'm getting a little low
on my oh yeah whatever whatever you need
in the meatball is nice you know what I
don't even think there's a refrigerator
in the meatball no there's there's a
fridge is there oh yeah we got a cooling
system minotaurs may is to find it okay
maybe maybe there's no fridge my
meatball is your meatball Chang if only
I could return the favor someday I'm
sure they're my right moment will rise
when they ask you who do you want to
co-star in the knotch film that's when
you'll know
no kidding dude you got it you got a
rock a cameo in there I mean I can play
any Swedish guy hello it's not friend my
best friend we make game you want to
make game knotch
wait you're not by the 8-ball no I'm
over here now I see you left [ __ ] have
you ever been to g'loona loaned [ __ ]
alert that was so beautiful the way you
said it as well it's like it's like the
Swedish Disneyland hey did you steal
did you steal [ __ ] I'm driving failure
for you I would never steal Peggy okay
here you go here's Peggy take take back
baby thank you let the ladies right here
please come back here fingers got an
affinity to me out
wait I don't think he has the leash on
him anymore yeah you guys I think you
dropped bag a vaguely gosh Peggy I see
him away to some older chickens now yeah
he just sort of ran in with his mama
chickens and I think he's happier there
I think we're gonna have to kill because
I don't like the way they shimmy shimmy
you gonna jump in the meatball no [ __ ] is
all yours oh how much how much does
fakie mean to you Jake Vegas everything
to me you know that the sad thing is I
don't think I'm gonna be able to take
Peggy with me when I leave I know you
can't take it with you it's much like
this world that we live in this life
that we live it's just you can accrue
all the figis you want but at the end of
the day know Peggy Peggy I think fake
legs sweat this is really cute it's very
sweet
look at the way he Nestle's in there oh
that's Fred Fran would never do such a
thing don't worry about it okay wait so
I can get away from there come here
spent thank you okay Peggy I got a let's
fill the house for a [ __ ]
oh my god we got my heart it's down to
one and a half hearts I'll save you
don't worry there we go okay so let's
let's just
Jablonski honey I need some medicine
turn around with my Peggy
I'll kill you as many times as I want
Jack so heartless when you asked for
your fiance's hand in marriage she said
other needs to wait for Jack I need one
Hall Pass no no you have to turn the
other you have to look away no no no
that's not how she did not mention any
Chaplinsky okay she did not specifically
say okay well if there's one youtube
channel you need to put aside before
it's dribbling ski games okay I won't
kill you I'm sorry but we're any equal
turns net let's say let's head up again
I have yet to kill you once we're
because we're even now
okay this is gonna sound a bit crazy but
we're we're both gonna jump oh really
like the scene in the matrix you know
where neo jumps the first time yeah the
red pill right after we rape it's got a
jump and it's you gotta take a leap of
faith oh god oh god sorry not like that
okay this is really trick look I love
this world you've created but this
little hitch right here I know it's a
work in progress
you got a jump and then okay okay and
then you got to get on the other side be
a nun chair on the opposite side of me
and then if you look down carefully I
don't know how I'm supposed to get
really that's gonna work yeah so you see
that the Swedish flag on the bottom okay
you got to hit that it's a bunch of beds
you'll make it safe just trust me what
do I do
I jump off this you want me to jump off
this yeah yeah yeah jump off this okay
wait can I jump first I'll show you how
it's done
okay okay okay okay okay and then just
know what so wait is there like a
there's a soft landing down there
buddy's right they should be a soft
lighting yeah yeah yes I landed on the
little plateau did you really yeah
oh you thought I was gonna die now did
you fool me once shame on you fool me
twice again shame on me you don't fool
me a third time
come on come on jump Jablonski Oh God
you know what yep tell me we'll win here
no no no no please no no no no no don't
do anything you don't need any you got
so many diamonds
leave them alone Jablonski oh hey
Jablonski wait you've had your way with
please do please calm down one time I
got my first look at you with your
dynamite you were getting ready to kill
me no I wasn't gonna do I wasn't a blade
ski oh good well place TNT too quick for
you oh yeah where you really tasted no
taste my golden scepter you can't get
past this two plates okay dude how many
how many hits do I have infinite help
Jablonski I will never die it's the
sweetest string that's American Gold
steel come on let's do this
I can't believe you did it
Oh first you killed Peggy and now you
kill me what is I did you killed Bambi's
we all saw it we all saw her I was there
trying to protect [ __ ] I drove on the
grenade for [ __ ] I miss him already
I can't believe the bed didn't work wait
where are you now oh wait of course
you'd kill me oh yeah I killed you all
right so now we kill each other equal
amount of times not really I think it's
safe to say no more fighting just I
think it's yeah yeah no more fighting
remember I don't even need to hold his
golden sword er I get threw out to the
ground okay
I could literally throw it to the ground
then do it go thank you we'll find your
new friend new figure okay I'll look for
favor hey I was thinking about ways to
battle the new algorithm oh yeah tell me
I just need to to go real hard on the
titles of the new content uh-huh and be
like sexy naked lady the next one's
gonna be called sex naked lady beauty
bye honey
oh that's gonna be the title of my next
video I would claim none of that has to
be in the video just needs to be in the
title no yeah
massive amount abuse in the first 30
seconds of download I think they have
like if you put sexy stuff it might get
you oh it might get me deactivate the
mighty algorithm all right well you know
Jeb Ling ski XP deep I sexy question
mark you see where I'm going with it
though yeah it totally alright let's
find you a new house buddy how about
this one here here's Alicia I'll let you
pick oh thank you no it's just you can't
just replace a loved one like that oh
there is [ __ ] number two I found a
thingy number two it doesn't work like
it so wait I just right click up now
with my it with my leash I think I
didn't work for me oh maybe I need to
right-click them just apparently let
them know maybe I need to feed him some
seed oh yeah maybe we're currently it's
almost at fifteen thousand donations
thank you very much
dude the chair
is called Nami National Alliance on
Mental Illness - great cause
great cause thank you everyone so far if
if we cured all mental illness in the
world we would we would save the world
some say there well will be enough
there's a more important charity there's
no shame in admitting when you need help
and that's that's the real deal I agree
that's the real deal there's people out
there to help you yeah and yeah and just
to talk to anyone that's close to you
yeah there's always someone that's gonna
listen oh there's a link in the
description to a tsunami yeah they're
like it's underneath my my stream as
well if you guys yeah can you kill a
mushroom cow with your bare hands I
don't know
don't try it hmm don't get hungry Jay
linskey
you would not hurt mushroom cow he's
like a father to me Felix are you a
vegetarian
pesky peri health tip the salmon is the
healthiest fish for you because of the
triple omega oils at 10 yeah you're like
you're welcome 10 years 10 years minimum
so your sushi guy dude big-time sushi
guy where are you in the world right now
I'm right next to you can you not see my
are you allowed to say where you live in
the road we're in the real we're in
buying crap Jablonski get it remember
what I said I'm in Los Angeles you know
I'm saying but you in the real world are
you in England I have anything yeah yeah
that's right
that's why we couldn't call each other
when we started off and that's why the
stream was delay
Freddie Mercury lead singer of Queen
he's from a little place in Africa
called the Sansa bar Zanzibar I heard
the best name for any any uh any play
any place in the world the sands it's
got two Z's it's the most fun thing to
say Sansa
can you try and get your chicken into
this boat yeah the chicken comes with me
wherever I go so this feels like an
ancient Middle Eastern riddle at the
same time as the oh my god dude I'm
glitching there's a glitch in the matrix
right now oh my god what's up today I
don't know
in the boat you're standing on top of
the boat so we're trying to jump up
honestly I can't get out you're good
okay I got I got oh what the chicken is
still there yeah so we have to sacrifice
our pens no too short hold on I don't
know how I feel about just naming this
new pet baby - that doesn't seem like a
respectful thing to the deceased [ __ ]
what are the new the new chick it's very
it's very classy it serves its own name
I can't just name something no it's
[ __ ] a you can definitely do that that
would be like if I named my children
Jack Black - and Jack Black 3 it just
doesn't seem right I mean you could do
it I could
I mean people named jr. right that is
true and I know I'd never really approve
that either no I'm sorry are you are you
Felix jr. no don't worry I have to say
I've always liked the name Felix I
almost named one of my boys Felix oh
nice thank you but at the last minute I
went with Thomas jr. Thomas is a good
name - well there's no jr. but my as you
may know my actual name is Thomas and I
named him Thomas so I I realized I broke
my own wait wait I'm a I'm a hypocrite
and I'm a self hater I mean fair enough
I don't understand what's happening here
either I'm just setting up so we can let
him go are we gonna send them out to sea
or something do we have to build them or
one that goes from here to the ocean do
you want to send them up to sea well I
thought I don't understand what we're
doing it will all come clear soon okay
don't worry about the details and
definitely don't kill this mushroom cat
with my bare hands
definitely dude he's super ray you
cannot touch he's like a father to me
okay it's so tempting now don't don't do
it
a bacon cheeseburger with mushrooms is
really delicious that's all I'm saying
and we've got like most of that here you
got the cheese you go yeah the mushroom
now all you need is a pig and you got a
bacon mushroom cheese birth well you
need the bread is that an upcoming
episode of Jablonski vlogs it should be
okay here we go
they get to I'm sorry
oh that was such a cruel way poor [ __ ]
I feel like you're saying hey I can't
kill Jack anymore things he loves
wait you loved him of course I loved
Peggy - oh my god I'm so sorry
I got it all wrong I thought you wanted
to get rid of it what this will not
happen again all right I know I know I
said I was done with this but I'm going
back in here I gotta get some supplies
no no no no no yeah Peggy would not
approve this here wait wait how do i
submerge so much now I'm burning in hell
forever apparently there's nothing I can
do to stop the burning I can't
why do you what I need to do this
honestly that was a total mistake I just
wanted to kill you with the golden sword
but I ended up burning down the thing
that you love most your minecraft house
on your personal property then you
brought me to I invited me as I was so
bad to my house at hunger games
minecraft you brought me here but in my
defense you killed me three times
I have good reasons for it jack you know
yes don't bring down someone was like it
was like a hundred
times worse than killing you was burning
down a big chunk of your house that
you'd worked so hard on with that house
you can't respawn that house and damage
this is like actually Gusev remodeling
I'm not gonna play Minecraft anymore
you've done it the house can go but my
most prized possession my minecraft Alex
when hey Felix
yes I've had so much fun unfortunately I
planned a little backyard barbecue today
you're saying that you burn down my
house
yeah and then you're ditching me yeah I
hate to burn and run but I got people
getting here in five minutes
and I haven't ordered the fried chicken
the pizza and I haven't even started the
barbecue I'm grilling burgers today all
right well but hey if you want to drop
by I think there's a nonstop from
Brighton to Lucknow you're gonna have to
stop in London and then come over to LA
you shall get here you know about
tomorrow's barbecue okay
our Monday barbecue well I'll let my
barbecue here and then you'll have your
barbecue in where la line let's uh I
look forward to someday high-fiving you
in the actual world yeah you two men it
was really good take care my friend all
the best good on you my bad I don't know
how to get at it good you're stuck here
I just walk away all right walk away
this is so sad of all the Jack burned
down my house oh my god
I'm so mad thanks for watching guys I'm
sorry about old that getting
difficulties what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]